animation it's the change from one CSS
style to another over the dimension of
time every animation has at least two
states a starting point and an ending
point when you move from start to finish
CSS will calculate all the values in
between in computer science this is
called inbetweening or a tween animation
imagine we have an element that we want
to fade in over a duration of one second
when the animation starts the browser
calculates a new a pasty value for every
frame rendered and it does so using a
linear timing function which means the
amount of change that occurs to the CSS
value is exactly the same for each unit
of time but in the real physical world
things rarely move at a perfect linear
pace things ease in ease out and change
the velocity gracefully you can do the
same in your CSS animations by providing
a timing function there are many
built-in functions where you can define
your own custom veggie acres the easiest
way to create an animation with CSS is
with a transition start by adding the
transition property to a selector the
first value is the property that you
want to animate in our case its opacity
the second value is the duration you can
define it in seconds or milliseconds now
whenever the opacity for this element
changes CSS will automatically handle
the animation for you for example we can
target the hover pseudo selector and
change the opacity to one and that's all
it takes to create a fade-in fade-out
animation with CSS we can refine this
animation by adding an additional value
for a delay or a timing function use a
built-in easing function or create your
own custom as the a curve but what if
you want to animate something forever or
in multiple steps keyframes allow you to
define animations independent of a
selector first give your keyframe
animation a name then define your
starting styles with from and your
ending styles with to any intermediate
styles or steps in the animation can be
defined as a percentage in relative time
to the starting point if your animation
is 4 seconds long then 25% would be 1
second into that animation you can use
this animation by referencing it as the
animation name in one of your selectors
give it a duration and timing function
then change the iteration count to
infinite to make it loop forever this
has been CSS animation in 100 seconds
hit the like button if you want to see
more short videos like this thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
you